so we saw how the Mack used 30-pin Sims
like this to sort its memory we'll look
later what sort of information the
computer stores in these things but for
now is going to look at how this
actually stores information now I'm sure
all of you aware it stores it in terms
of binary digits or bits but actually
what we're really interested in just
storing a single bit and we can put them
together to form lots of memory so to
understand how the memory works we need
to look at some of the basic digital
logic circuits we can build using logic
gates now over on numberphile Matt
Parker introduced these using dominoes
to create various things we're going to
look at them in terms of the electronic
chips so you can buy your basic logic
circuits in integrated circuits like
this this one's for or gates so here's
you put them together in electronic
circuit to build memory now this is a
bit odd because normally these are just
used to process or combine various
inputs but if we connect them in a
specific way we can actually get them to
store information at least until the
powers turned off so what we've got here
are two very basic electronic circuits
we've got a NAND gate here and an or
gate in this chip here these chips come
with four and gates or four or gates
together and if we remember from the
numberphile video a NAND gate is on when
both of its inputs are on if either
input is off then the output is off so
in this case I wired it up to a simple
LED so that we can see the output of one
of the an gates and I've wired both of
the inputs to the positive voltage rail
because we use positive 5 volts to
represent in true or 1 in binary and we
use ground or 0 volts to represent false
or 0 in binary
now that's generally what we use is what
was called TTL logic these days you use
different voltage levels and so on but
the principles is the same you have one
voltage which represents false or zero
and another voltage which is generally
higher that represents one or true so if
I take and if I just move these over so
you can see what I'm doing
so both of these are currently connected
to logic 1 or 5 volts if I disconnect
one and connect it to the logic 0 you
can see that immediately that light goes
off because the and gate has now got one
input zero one input at 1 1 and 0 is 0
by the laws of boolean algebra so we can
combine these in different ways and
again if I put the back in one boat one
it's on put them both to zero then
they're both off over here I've got an
or gate and if you remember back from
the numberphile video and all gate is on
when either of its inputs are on or both
of them on so I'm going to rewire the
circuit to do that so often you'll get
books like this which will give you
details of things the quad input
positive or Gates has the inputs on pins
1 and 2 and the output of one pin 3 the
and gate 7 402 has the inputs on pins 2
and 3 in the outputs on pin 1 so connect
the output to pin 3 and we can now start
to connect the inputs now both cases
whoops I'm just short of the year I just
draw it video yeah just shorted the
power supply which is worth making noise
so we can let both of these two little
cables or melted pin 0 and if we now
unplug that and plug it into that I just
broken everything in fiber check I have
this gets headed to there yes that's
right and I've either fried everything
on here in out sending it off and on
again
I am indeed turning it off and on again
here in the hope that I haven't just
shorted everything else we pause there I
think we might need to pause it smokes
cleared and we just had a slight problem
with the power supply but we're back and
running now there's a little hamster
running around in the wheel
power everything at the moment so we've
rewired this so that the output of the
or gate is now connected to the LED and
these are both tied to logic zero
through these resistors here if I now
connect any of these two logic one the
input comes on such input to connect
logic one input one the input comes on
and of course because it's an or gate if
I connect the second input at the same
time then they're both on we also get
other versions of these chips and these
are called NAND gates or nor gates and
they work in exactly the same way they
take two inputs and they add them
together but immediately following that
built into the chip is what's called a
not gate which inverts the output so
it's the opposite of a NAND gate its
output is off when both of its inputs
are on so we can open this up alright
going to take the and chip out
yup and pop this chip thing can be a
pain because you have to bend all the
legs to fit in there we get so that's
now in place so going to rewire it now
to use a NAND gate that I've popped in
there so I connect the output to pin
three of this circuit and the lead of
course comes on because both inputs one
and two a wired to zero normally a NAND
gate would be off because both of its
input at zero but this is the opposite
of that so briefly symbols at zero it's
now on so if we connect input two to
five volts it stays on because zero and
one is zero the inverse of that is one
but if we connect input one as well to
five volts then the LED goes off because
one and one is one the opposite of that
is zero so the lead is now but as soon
as we disconnect one of the pins it
comes back on and one of the fascinating
things about NAND gates is that you
could build a whole computer
just using the circuits on this chip you
need lots of that meeting more than four
but what we're going to do today is use
not a NAND gate to start with but an or
gate which is an or then knotted to
actually build some memory so over here
is what I prepared earlier we have a
quad input nor gate so this is for nor
gates so what I'm going to do is wire to
nor gates into a circuit so that it'll
actually store the information that we
put in it I'm going to use this one on
the left here and this one over here let
me just check the wiring diagram we have
pins one is the output of the nor gate
two and three of the inputs and on the
other side pin 13 is the output and pin
11 and 12 so I'm going to connect the
output of this nor gate on the
right-hand side to the input of the one
on the left-hand side
you call them a and B or C episode we
connect the output of nor gate B to the
input of nor gate a and I'm going to
connect the output of nor gate a back to
the input of nor gate B it's a very
tight fit we get so we've got these two
things crossed over but the amplitude
one is connected to the input of the
other and just to make sure the circuit
works I'm just going to put some
resistors to tie the other input to zero
volts to our logic zero this means that
I can make them logic one or logic zero
just by touching the leg of the resistor
with a wire connected to five volts
later the demonstration so the other
thing I'm going to do is I've connected
the output of nor gate a to this wire
here and I'm just going to put a lead
across that wire to ground like so and
I'm going to do the same on the other
side so I'll connect that up like so
there and we'll see this lead is now
come on so now get a fly wire plug this
in to 5 volts like that and if I touch
this one this ledge comes on and it
stays on if I touch that one that leg
goes off and this one
comes on and stays on this circuit is
remembering its state and we can do that
by just driving a signal into the chip
and it'll stay like that until I turn
the power off we need to look at how
this circuit works so I'm going to draw
it out but before we do that it will be
useful to refresh our memory of how an
or gate works so that's an or gate and
it has two inputs which we will label as
a and B it has an output which we label
as Q so we can build up a truth table
for this so normally with an or gate
zero or zero would be zero but we're
inverting it because it's an or gate or
the output is 1 0 or 1 is 1
but it's inverted so the output is 0 1
or 0 is 1 which is diverted to the at 1
0 1 or 1 is 1 inverted to the output is
0 so that's the truth table for an or
gate now let's have a look at the
circuit that we used over there so we
had our first nor gate and we also had
our second or gate like that and we've
got the inputs to these like so and we
took the output from here and connected
it to the input of that one and we took
the output from here and connected it
here we've now got two inputs left that
we're not using and I'm going to label
them as R because that's what we use to
reset it and we've got s which is what
we used to set it for to store a bit
we've also got two outputs and I'm going
to label the first one Hugh and the
other one we're going to call this not Q
in the way we do that is we draw a line
over the top to say that this is not Q
now the thing we have to remember about
these circuits is that they don't switch
the output instantaneously when the
inputs switches there is a slight very
short delay and depending on what type
of chip you get there's always a slight
delay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
draw out a truth table for this so we've
got input R I've got input s we've got
output Q an output Q not Q but these are
also inputs to this so I'm actually
going to put in Q Prime and not Q Prime
to start with this is at 0 this is at 0
we don't know what these values are so
we'll leave them blank what's the next
value
q going to be so it's going to be zero
order with the current value of not Q
knotted so that's going to be wrestling
to this Q naught Q naught it not Q
knotted is of course Q because the two
knots cancel out so the value of Q prime
is whatever the old value of Q was
effectively same happens for naught Q
Prime that's s which is zero order with
the old value of Q knotted so we get
naught Q so as long as the two inputs at
zero you get the same values propagating
through the circuit but what happens if
we set s to be one we leave our zero so
a new value of Q is going to be the old
value of not Q odd with zero so it's
going to be naught naught Q again so
it's going to be Q a new value of naught
Q is going to be s which is one order
with whatever the value of Q was not it
now if you or anything with one if you
think about the truth table the answer
is always 1 so naught Q is going to be 0
because it's not of 1 so we're going to
get a 0 in there so we can feed those
back in again we've still got 0 and 1 is
the input here we now know that the
output of Q Bar or not Q is 0 so what's
the new value of Q going to be well it's
the output of not Q which is 0 board
with 0 which is 0 knotted which is 1 the
output of Q prime is going to be 1 and
the output of Q Bar Prime
well that's still one Ord with whatever
the output of key was before so call it
Q that's always going to be 1 knotted so
that's going to be 0 and if we run those
values through again so we've got 0 1 1
0 then we get the same values out 1 0
but the interesting thing is when this
becomes 0 and that becomes 0 again Q
still at 1 not Q is still at 0 we run
the circuit through here the new value
of Q is the old value of not Q order is
zero knotted that's one and not Q prime
is s which is zero with the old value of
Q which was one so that's one knotted as
zero so it stays the same when you get
the same input coming through so it
actually continues and we could do the
same thing with the reset and you'll
find if you work it through that it
resets it and all the values go to zero
so that very simple circuit will
actually store the state if it's set and
if it's reset and you can actually build
up a complete memory circuit because you
can put some very simple digital logic
in front of that to generate the right s
or our signal based on the value of a
bit and whether you want to store it or
not and everybody was going to click on
that one what turned out that the video
behind that was a person talking about
that fight only that will fall over what
that won't move here we go ready and
eventually the yours